hi I'm Tim from wired and we're here
actually outside the convention center
where comic-con has taken over downtown
San Diego there's more stuff happening
outside the show this year than ever
before there's a big adventure time
playground for kids Neill Blomkamp's in
the movie Elysium has a big spaceship to
go take photos of the TV show Grimm has
a big trailer and you go check out clip
from the show Tim Burton's new movie
Frankenweenie it's a big area set up we
can go check out clips from the movie
really Scott's new TV show coma you can
go in get checked out by doctors watch a
live surgery there's anything even an
area set up we can go Skype with your
friends and all this stuff is actually
pretty cool because Comic Con sold out
in 90 minutes this year so if you
weren't able to get a ticket like most
people you can still go around the area
outside the show and experience a lot of
this really really cool stuff so be sure
to check out more coverage on wired com
you